[Applause]
when the voting stopped in germany the
guessing game began
the nation's two biggest parties
apparently neck and neck in the race for
the chancellorship
but then a small gap developed the
social
spd
edging into a lead over the cdu that's
the party of angela merkel
so after 16 years of having merkel in
charge
this man is now the front runner to
become germany's next chancellor
[Applause]
we are a pragmatic party that knows how
to govern
we are a confident party that wants to
work to ensure that we have a better
future in germany
he was cheered by party loyalists at
gatherings across germany
at this one in berlin
people knew that such a close result
would lead to lengthy talks for a
coalition government but still
there was a mood of celebration
these sbd supporters have endured so
many years of electoral under
achievement but tonight they think
they've got something to celebrate now
ahead of us is a protracted period when
this nation built a political governing
coalition
but these people think it will end with
their man olef schultz
as germany's next chancellor
the truth is that even his own
supporters think that schultz is a bit
dull
that he is seen as safe and capable
he's been a really good candidate for us
and that's why i've been campaigning so
much on the streets and we really think
that he can you know do a difference in
germany and do a difference in europe
especially and that we need kind of
someone who knows what to do when to do
and has a plan
across berlin the man who has struggled
to grasp merkel's legacy the cdu's armin
lachette wants the clear favorite in
this election now putting on a brave
face
after his party's worst electoral
performance
no certain numbers but we can already
say we can't be satisfied with the
result
germany will need a coalition government
again annelina berbock leader of the
third place greens is already being
touted as the king maker in this story
[Applause]
election chaos says this headline
uncertainty is probably more accurate
but for a country as big and unshakable
as this one
uncertainty
feels unsettling
adam parsons sky news berlin